[Musique]
merci c'est gentil
mesdames et messieurs mesdames Messieurs
les élus chers spectateurs
c'est avec un immense plaisir que
l'équipe du prix peut vous accueille
pour le lancement de la saison
culturelle 2023-2024
je souhaite rapidement revenir sur la
saison qui vient de s'écouler pour vous
dire l'enthousiasme qui a été le nôtre à
vous recevoir et à vous proposer des
spectacles variés et de grande qualité
vous êtes d'ailleurs toujours plus
nombreux à assister au spectacle qui
pour la plupart étaient complets
votre fidélité au prisme est le
carburant de notre motivation et de
notre envie de continuer à vous
surprendre à vous émerveiller à vous
divertir
[Applaudissements]
au delà des spectacles et des nombreuses
expositions qui ont jalonné cette année
nous avons aussi et avec la
participation des services de la commune
puis rénover le bar pour que vous
puissiez dîner les soirs de spectacle et
voir faire en famille ou entre amis dans
un lieu chaleureux accueillant je vois
qu'il y en a qui ont déjà
[Applaudissements]
voilà il y a des connaisseurs il me
semble nécessaire de pouvoir remercier
devant vous l'ensemble de l'équipe que
dis-je de l'équipage du prisme qui
travaille chaque jour à la Russie de
notre projet culturel à la qualité de
l'accueil que nous vous réservons et au
bon fonctionnement de cette honorable
institution
merci pour
j'ai la meilleure équipe en fait
après la projection des films et la
présentation de la nouvelle
programmation vous assisterez au concert
du groupe de jazz Adrian clartriaux
on est en famille dont la notoriété
n'est plus à faire voilà nous nous
retrouverons au bar récemment baptisé La
Ruche merci Dalila autour d'un cocktail
sucré salé pour échanger sur les
différents projets culturels à venir
nous vous invitons à embarquer avec nous
pour des destinations inédites à la
découverte de spectacles qui éveilleront
vos sens et nourriront votre imagination
très bonne soirée à tous et je vais
laisser la parole à Monsieur le Maire de
la ville merci
[Applaudissements]
bon je viens toujours avec mon cerveau
de mon
iPad
rien
alors mes amis sur les élus
chers amis fidèles spectateur du prisme
heureux donc de vous retrouver nombreux
ce soir pour la présentation donc cette
nouvelle saison
très bon chiffre d'ailleurs pour la
saison culturelle 2022 2023
un pari réussi de renforcer le côté
populaire de la programmation de faire
le choix d'une culture pour tous pour
tous les publics bien sûr et accessibles
à tous le spectacle c'est un plaisir
simple c'est se cultiver ou se divertir
en passant juste un bon moment seul ou
en couple
les amis ou en famille c'est simple
le bonheur c'est simple c'est déjà
d'apprécier ce que l'on a en soi le
bonheur et la culture ça réveille ce
qu'il y a en soi
vous avez été au rendez-vous de cette
saison et votre présence en nombre ce
soir le montre on dit mon me dit dans
que on est près de 600 contre 380 l'an
dernier
c'est surprenant c'est une bonne
surprise donc ça prouve que c'est bien
parti pour cette nouvelle saison ce
résultat c'est pas un hasard c'est le
fruit d'un très important bien sûr de
nos agents
exister notre directeur du prisme Thomas
perron que vous avez vu avant moi on
peut et son équipe d'ailleurs pour le
dynamisme et leur mobilisation et bien
sur notre mer adjoint à la Culture
Laurent mazouri vous allez voir tout à
l'heure donc on peut les applaudir
[Applaudissements]
la culture
chers amis ça permet de s'évader de
découvrir de nouveaux univers de
nouveaux paysages de nouvelles émotions
de nouvelles potentialité en soi se
cultivées tant de points communs avec le
voyage bien sûr tout simplement alors
vous l'aurez peut-être compris en voyant
le visuel de cette nouvelle saison mais
cette année nous proposons de vous
emmener en voyage de vous faire
embarquer sur une folle croisière qui
vous fera découvrir ou redécouvrir
d'ailleurs tous les styles tous les
environnements culturels le théâtre la
musique le jazz l'humour la danse tous
les arts du vieux vent parce que la
culture
c'est la vie mais je vais bien
évidemment laisser Tom j'ai laissé
Laurent mazzerine notre mère adjoint la
culture et Thomas perron vous présenter
plus en détail cette nouvelle saison
donc
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes nombreux c'est bien bonsoir à
tous et à toutes
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs bienvenue à bord
de ce vol extraordinaire au cœur de
notre nouvelle saison culturelle alors
pour ceux qui ne sauraient pas ce voyage
sera intégralement filmé par TV 78 en
direct je vous remercie la réalisation
qui est là ce soir charité bien ordonné
commence toujours par soi-même surtout
dans le voyage donc ne vous étonnez pas
si vous êtes et vous serez très
certainement des stars ce soir grâce à
TV 78 alors attaché vos ceintures
ajuster vos sièges préparez-vous à
embarquer pour un voyage hors du commun
ou l'art la musique le théâtre et bien
d'autres merveilles vous attendent à
chaque escale
à vos portes armement des toboggans
contre les vis-à-vis préparez-vous s'il
vous plaît au démonstration de sécurité
je suis ce soir à votre capitaine de la
culture et vous verrez nous emprunterons
des voies aériennes ou maritimes en
fonction des moments et je vous invite
donc à larguer les amarres de la
monotonie quotidienne pour embarquer
dans un périple haut en couleur riche en
découvertes et parsemées
comme dans tout mon voyage vous
demandons de garder à l'esprit que les
horaires peut être sujet à des
changements
évidemment il n'y a pas de remboursement
il n'y a que des avoir mais pas de
panique nous avons prévu des excursions
qui vous laisseront des souvenirs
inoubliables que vous rappellerez
raconter à vos amis en disant ah tu sais
à la saison culturelle j'ai vécu des
aventures que même il y a des Jones
n'aurait pas su affronter alors attachez
votre imagination préparez-vous à
décoller certaines de nos escales seront
consacrées à l'art contemporain vous
aurez l'occasion de découvrir des
peintures abstraites et énigmatiques
d'ailleurs que même Sherlock Holmes se
répertexte si les voyait et vous pourrez
contempler ces chef-d'oeuvre et vous
dire je ne comprends rien mais c'est
tellement joli
ensuite nous vogrons vers des escales
musicales imaginez-vous en train
d'assister un concert ou les musiciens
improvisent comme si leur vie même en
dépendait vous serez entraîné par la
magie des notes et vous direz ces
artistes ont tellement de talents qu'ils
pourraient faire danser même les
pingouins de l'Antarctique nous
passerons parmi vous tout à l'heure pour
les réservations de toutes ces belles
croisières pour les amateurs de théâtre
nombre ce soir
merci nous avons prévu des escales
hautes en couleur et en haute mer vous
pourrez assister à des représentations
aussi incroyables qui seront autant de
visites de pays magiques et inconnus des
pays où l'on jongle avec les mots et les
émotions et lorsque le rideau tombera
vous serez ébloui et vous exclamerez
c'était tellement bluffant que j'ai cru
que j'étais dans un épisode de la 4e
dimension pour cela il y a un forfait
spécial le personnel passera parmi vous
tout à l'heure pour prendre les
inscriptions à ses escales
nous ferons un détour par le pays des
comédies légères ou les rires résonnent
comme un douche chant d'oiseau dans une
forêt enchantée vous y découvrirez des
talents comiques afin de vous faire
oublier tous vos soucis le temps d'un
éclat de rire salvateur nous mettrons
également le cas vers le pays de la
poésie ou les mots sont des îles
paradisiaques suspendus dans une mer de
sens là des plumes talentueuses vous
emporteront dans un tourbillon de verre
envoûtant ou la beauté des maux vous
caressera l'âme telle une brise légère
après avoir exploré ces contrées
humoristiques et politiques nous
atteindrons les terres des mélodies
enchanteresse des musiciens Virtuos
comme ceux de ce soir des chanteurs aux
voix de d'ange et des danseurs gracieux
vous inviteront à une danse des sens
n'oubliez pas de cocher cette option
dans votre cabine
fermez les yeux et laissez-vous emporter
par ces rythmes entraînants et les
harmonies en vous tentent attention
risque de mouvement spontanés du pied et
de la tête mais notre voyage ne
s'arrêtera pas là vous aurez également
l'opportunité de découvrir des
expositions photographiques qui vous
transporteront dans des contrées
lointaines n'hésitez pas à cocher
également cette formule dans votre
abonnement
vous tant contemplerez ces images donc
époustouflantes et vont murmurer ces
photographes sont de véritables
aventuriers ils auraient pu rivaliser
avec les explorateurs du passé et en
parlant d'explorateurs un de nos arrêts
vous emmènera dans un monde fantastique
celui de la littérature vous découvrirez
des romans captivants des poèmes
envoûtants et des contes qui vous feront
rêver éveillés vous serez immergé dans
ces récits envoûtant et vous direz je me
suis tellement perdu dans ces pages que
j'ai failli manquer mon arrêt de bus par
ailleurs si vous êtes en retard au
retour d'une excursion 100 euros vous
sera facturé mesdames et messieurs notre
phase de décollage culturel touche à sa
fin la phase de décollage uniquement
vous savez la plus dangereuse dans les
vols mais ce n'est que le début de notre
voyage de ce soir les souvenirs que vous
emporterez avec vous resteront à jamais
gravés dans votre cœur nous espérons que
vous apprécierez cette traversée
artistique rapide et que vous en
sortirez grandi et enrichi et nous aussi
au nom de toute l'équipe de notre prisme
quadrimoteur de notre Passi Prisma
Pacifique Princess de la saison
culturelle d'Élancourt du maire
d'Élancourt de tous les mousses et
moussaillons de l'équipe municipale que
je salue et qui sont présents ici c'est
ce soir je tiens à vous remercier
d'avoir pris le risque pardon d'avoir
choisi d'embarquer avec nous nous
souhaitons un excellent voyage dans le
monde de l'art de la musique du théâtre
et de la littérature et rappelez-vous
dans la vie comme dans les voyages
culturels l'important c'est de profiter
du voyage même si vous vous perdez en
route
je vais vous laisser dans quelques
instants entre les mains notre équipage
de choix qui va vous décrire plus
précisément toutes nos escales
théâtrales donc vous vous préparez vos
valises vos passeports vos transat votre
crème solaire mais ne vous l'aurez pas
comme dirait quelqu'un je connais bien
voyager avec notre équipage est un
plaisir mais discrètement insidieusement
c'est aussi se cultiver parfois sans se
rendre compte alors ils sont les voiles
de la joie ils sont les voiles de la
créativité et partons ensemble à la
découverte de cette saison saison
culturelle qui nous fera naviguer sur
les flots de l'humour de la poésie de la
musique et de la visuelle bon voyage à
tous et surtout préparez-vous à vous en
mettre plein les yeux et les oreilles
PNC à vos portes des armements des
toboggans mesdames et messieurs
attention à la chute éventuelle d'objets
lors de l'ouverture des coffres à
bagages et merci donc d'avoir choisi ce
soir notre compagnie le prisme Airways
nous avons hâte de vous retrouver à
nouveau tout au long de la saison sur
nos sièges
alors ce qu'il faut savoir
n'avez pas encore payé vous avez 30% de
la du spectacle évidemment mais là
maintenant ça marche alors ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
nouvelles saisons culturelle
sans une tradition qui est celle de voir
ce qui s'est passé et tout voyage
appelle aussi à la projection des
diapositives vous vous souvenez quand on
était beaucoup plus jeune c'était une
tradition il y avait cette bonne
après-midi du dimanche où vos amis vous
présenter leur diapo vont vous montrer
là où ils étaient allés et où vous
n'aviez pas été le tout en 300 500 600
diapositives 4 heures et vous faisiez
tous semblant disons que c'est
extraordinaire et bien nous n'aurons pas
cette tradition et je vous me demande
donc de nous réserver quelques instants
pour la projection des diapositives du
voyage et des voyages de la saison
passée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien maintenant que le parasol Émile les
vacances peuvent commencer je vais vous
laisser entre les mains de nos deux
lieutenants de vaisseau le sémillant
Patrice carmouz et son acolyte non
anonyme Thomas Peron qui vont nous
détailler ces magnifiques escales
culturelles Thomas
le parasol vous attend
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir Patrice bonsoir
j'ai cherché mes fiches on sait jamais
ça pourrait aider
alors on est ravi d'être ici on va vous
faire faire un voyage dans le temps dans
le futur avec la saison qui s'annonce
absolument et
Laura avait raison elle est au théâtre
c'est faire un voyage c'est je sais pas
moi c'est entrer dans un musée dans un
château dans une église dans ce qu'on
veut c'est aussi dans le théâtre c'est
entré dans un parc aquatique parfois
parc d'attraction enfin c'est faire un
voyage seul en famille c'est faire un
road trip aller à l'aventure et puis on
peut y voir comme ça je ne sais pas des
un océan désert le lac c'est beau ce que
je dis non
il suffit de il suffit de rêver éveiller
absolument c'est ça c'est notre métier
c'est votre métier voilà alors voilà
vous attachez vos ceintures comme disait
Laurent vous êtes vous vérifiez vos
vis-à-vis et on est parti pour le
décollage on est parti allez
alors
ce décollage justement je croyais que
vous n'ayez pas un petit instrument avec
vous je dois ramener à
quel moment c'était ah bah c'est Laura
c'est là si on veut non allez vous devez
devenir on va est-ce que vous aviez un
petit truc dans un petit vous êtes trop
can de roller vous moi j'ai un truc de
jeunes
snowboard ah oui c'est ça
en fait regardez c'est un truc de jeune
donc ça peut vous plaire quand même
absolument vous savez ce que vous devez
faire plutôt que de parler si on regarde
un petit bout des claquettes après je
vais faire des claquettes parce que moi
je peux faire des trucs comme ça mais
vachement moyen quoi regarder le film
c'est mieux non c'est mieux allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle est lourde la valoche ah ouais
figurez-vous vous savez pourquoi j'ai
une valise
vous revenez de voyage peut-être pour
vous asseoir c'est l'âge en fait dans je
suis allé faire un tour au théâtre
aux Français oui ou français ou alors
weshio
c'était une pièce de Corneille
ou de racines
est arrivée comme ça et quand elle était
rayée vous savez ce qu'on va le faire
alors elle marche elle met un pied comme
ça on se dit donc ça y est elle a
compris elle va le mettre encore pas du
tout elle met l'autre après et l'autre
après c'est pas comment le faire je sais
pas comment elle fait à chaque fois le
gauche le droit le gauche se former et
alors et alors j'étais pas savoir quand
elle arrive là je vais vous le faire
parce que je me souviens exactement le
texte tellement ça m'a ému elle dit et
ton cœur
ma femme est vidée au théâtre avec moi
elle est restée là-bas vous avez aimé
trois jours
est-ce que c'est le français j'en sais
rien ça fait trois jours que tu l'as
laissé ça fait trois jours que je l'ai
pas ah tu es pénètre sa valise et tout
enfin du coup ça va mieux tranquille
ouais bah oui je sais
tout ça pour dire que bon il faut jamais
être impressionné quand on vote jamais
c'était un petit extrait adapté des
dialogues de Roland dubia mais il faut
jamais être impressionné quand on vote
au théâtre absolument la programmation
que vous avez et nous c'est pour ça on
fait avec tout l'argent spectre et du
théâtre et théâtre et du bon théâtre
alors on a par exemple
tirer d'un roman qui a été un
best-seller de 850 000 exemplaires
900000 je crois au même 1900
Molière 2022 meilleur prix
d'interprétation féminine
voilà pas mal pas mal c'est c'est une
histoire extrêmement touchante
extrêmement voilà c'est la vraie vie
noviano avec ses joies ces peines et
mais c'est très
onirique c'est magnifique et
j'avais des fiches j'avais tout préparé
sur des fiches hein ces fichiers sortir
les fils tu es jolie pas une avant bravo
qui avait fait déjà fallait pas le dire
cette saison fallait pas le dire avec
Pierre Arditi et absolument et puis et
puis ah oui une pièce disons qu'elle
dérac gaine naissance
extraordinaire
[Musique]
par contre je ne chanterai pas
[Applaudissements]
tout à l'heure hein
féminine et puis quel personnage et puis
c'est surtout c'est c'est chez nous
c'est chez vous oui absolument et un
personnage absolument extraordinaire
alors
dans la pièce on dit mais parce que
quand il jouait du bas qui chantonnaient
[Musique]
d'édition avec quelques réticences à
faire que jouer quelqu'un du bac qui
chantait né par dessus évidemment
c'était un peu particulier et puis il a
il a fait quelques concerts puis il
arrêtait très vite il s'est enfermé 32
ans à 32 ans et il ne fait plus que des
enregistrements absolument voilà et cela
la pièce est extraordinaire on peut voir
quelques extraits
[Musique]
je suis arrivé à 2h du matin je me suis
garé devant les grilles du cimetière à
7h du matin j'ai vu de la lumière à
l'intérieur de chez elle j'ai frappé je
m'attendais à trouver un vieil homme je
sais les idées reçues sont stupides en
tout cas je ne m'attendais pas du tout à
elle et puis qui peut s'attendre à elle
elle m'a fait entrer m'a offert du café
elle portait une robe de chambre ses
cheveux étaient ramenés en chignon j'ai
trouvé incroyable irréel comme une
apparition et puis à la sortie ces
registres à ce moment là j'ai pensé il
faut que je sache d'où elle vient et ce
qu'elle fait là
au cours de ma deuxième visite je l'ai
observé nettoyer les tombes tes pensées
il faut que je sache d'où elle vient et
ce qu'elle fait là
[Musique]
merci d'accueillir
en tout cas la manière que vous avez eu
d'interpréter Max au soir je ne l'avais
jamais entendu auparavant alors vous
croyez qui peut être le plus grand au
moins l'un des plus grands je crois que
c'est possible oui
[Musique]
l'entendez pas je pense qu'au voir parle
des championnements oh oui je chantonne
quand je joue je le fais tout le temps
vous jouez du piano
le monde entier est fascinant
[Musique]
je suis là je serai toujours là
j'ai toujours eu cette peur qui meurt
avant moi il est si fragile
jamais laissé le choix quand il était
petit c'est ça qui me dérange tu
n'aurais jamais été Glen
[Musique]
vous voulez faire un disque avec des
craquements et un pianiste qui chantonne
par dessus Jean-Sébastien Bach oui
d'accord
on va pas en vendre un seul ah si ma
mère l'achètera je vous le garantie
c'est pour le voyage la comédie c'était
un truc moi je voulais éviter d'avoir le
canard j'ai pris la guitare mais parce
que le câlin je voulais pas moi j'ai des
gens qui me connaissent
cours de zoologie ça ressent plutôt un
hippocampe ah mais oui mais nous sur
vous avez des canards comme ça c'est le
timbre générique comme le frigidaire
c'est la voiture
parce que des meilleurs comédies vois
que je connais c'est le canard avec qui
avait été adapté par euh il fallait que
ça raccorde avec
il y avait une histoire dans ce canard à
l'orange vous savez c'était l'histoire
d'un d'un mari qui voulait reconquérir
sa femme devant son amant et donc il
réutilisait son amour et donc il lui il
lui a raconté des histoires que l'autre
ne comprenait absolument pas il avait
une qui ne faisait rire que moi je peux
vous la raconter quand même ça a été dit
l'autre jour j'étais dans un asile de
fou
et je prenais bien un four en laisse bon
comme ça il n'était pas encore tout à
fait guéri quoi et tout d'un coup on
passe sous un arbre et là il y a un
pigeon
sur la tête du Fou
je suis là je dis à l'infirmière
pardon vous pouvez pas l'essuyer à
l'infirmière me dire non le règlement
interdit absolument aux infirmières de
grimper aux arbres voyez qui est fou qui
n'est pas fou en effet et d'ailleurs
dans les dans les campings il y a
souvent des des hypo oui forcément parce
que l'hippocampe
je vais là-bas parce que c'est un métier
cette année au dessus c'est le soleil
n'est-ce pas Thomas on va parler de
scalpel peut-être au scalpel Bruno
Salomone David Sardou de frangins mise
en scène de mon copain Thierry Harcourt
pas les meilleurs amis du monde alors il
y en a qui aiment la femme de l'autre et
l'autre enfin cette histoire de femme de
truffes on comprend rien
pas vraiment et deux acteurs formidables
généreux
on a ça on a quoi on a drôle de genre
aussi drôle de gens alors attendez on va
on va on va vous faire une révélation
rester vous connaissez Victoriaville
[Musique]
elle est très très bon c'est sa passion
et c'est très drôle c'est extrêmement
drôle et ben là aussi on a quelques
extraits
qu'est-ce que tu veux c'est curieux à ta
façon de réagir on dirait que tu le sais
je sais quoi pourquoi je suis venu ou
qu'est-ce que tu as à me dire
[Musique]
il n'est pas de moi
que le garder et qu'on divorce et merde
pourquoi tu dis merde parce que c'est
emmerder pour toi mais tu as dit merde
comme si c'était emmerdant pour toi
tu ne me poses pas la question qui est
ce type qui sait
j'ai pas été plus jaloux que n'importe
quelle année ah oui qui disait à maman
tiens on a qu'à le laisser dans la
poussette dans le bus on pourra le
donner
tu peux m'ouvrir
[Musique]
je me sens pas très bien
tu es une merde dis-le tu es une merde
[Musique]
jamais j'aurais imaginé que tu étais
capable de ça tu mens tu veux me faire
du mal partout les moyens
je t'ai dit que moi je ne mens pas c'est
impossible
tu crois
[Musique]
non mais tu comprends pas ce que je t'ai
dit François
j'ai un cancer de la prostate
[Musique]
je suis un homme
calme-toi mais comment tu veux que je me
calme ma femme et ton bonhomme
[Musique]
pas un alors crois-moi c'est pas ça le
problème
c'est pas parce que son père est en vie
aurait à quoi c'est du cul
que sa fille est aussi
sur ton truc
je suis un homme
[Musique]
bravo vous êtes content vous me l'avez
toutes les craqué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la grande Zaza c'est pas loin
s'il vous plaît oui oui je vous écoute
oui qu'est-ce qu'il y a alors voilà
alors qu'est-ce que oui
et puis vous tapez le lit parce que on
va faire une y'a pas de problème de
photo afin que ça va bien se passer
[Musique]
4 étoiles et tout ça le personnel est
exceptionnel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense que pour les pour les acteurs
ça doit être quelque chose de terrible
de se retrouver seul comme ça face à un
public il faut aller les chercher il
faut les convaincre et puis il y a des
fois formidables il y a ma copine
Marianne James absolument spectacle
interactif cours de chant sur la voie
cours de chant elle fait monter les gens
sur scène la vraie ça me rappelle
toujours une anecdote souvenait de la
vie éternof tranquille quand Daniel
Gélin s'aperçoit que c'est son
assistante qui était sa maîtresse qui
traitait plus mal que tout qui avait
échangé les deux bébés et il y a cette
scène qui est devenue culte où il fait
la [__]
[Musique]
demander d'en faire plusieurs comme ça
il disait j'en prendrai une au montage
en fait il a gardé
c'est vrai que avec la voix on peut
faire des choses formidable on a aussi
André Dussollier André Dussollier
de texte je peux me permettre un un
petit truc allez parce que il y a un
texte que fait du soulier qui est
formidable que vous connaissez peut-être
vous connaissez La Bella ténia la
bellaténiens c'est lui qui a écrit j'ai
du bon tabac dans ma tabatière ce que
tout le monde pensait être une chanson
pour enfants qui est en réalité le tabac
et la tabatir c'est plutôt quelque chose
de plus sexuel et c'est lui qui a écrit
aussi ce texte que fait
du soulier dans son spectacle qui
s'appelle l'homo et la chose aujourd'hui
un tout petit extrait madame quel est
votre mot et sur le mot et sur la chose
on vous a dit souvent le mot vous a fait
souvent la chose aussi de la chose et du
mot vous pouvez dire quelque chose et je
gâcherai que le mot vous plaît beaucoup
que la chose pour moi voici quel est mon
mot et sur le mot et sur la chose
j'avouerai que j'aime le mot je voudrais
que j'aime la chose mais c'est la chose
avec le mot mais c'est le mot avec la
chose
autrement la chose et le mot à mes yeux
serait peu de choses je crois même en
faveur du mot pouvoir ajouter quelque
chose une chose qui donne aux mots tout
l'avantage sur la chose c'est qu'on peut
dire encore le mot
alors qu'on ne fait plus la chose
un très joli texte
on aura Verino aussi Verino formidable
quarantenaire
150 millions de vues sur Internet 900
spectacles c'est toujours complet et
absolument et qu'est-ce qu'on aura
d'autres aussi
non non
je veux pas trop te parler là je suis à
une encours prisme pour la c'est Macron
marc Jolivet
si Jean-Michel fourgouse voudrais entrer
au gouvernement je lui ai demandé
je te rappelle après
on a tout le panel au niveau des âges on
a à peu près tout au niveau du style
donc on a un film à regarder allez allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merde vous jouez de fou oh
bon ben puisque c'est comme ça vous êtes
vilain pas toi toi je te garde
toi ça va c'est la faute du petit là
oui c'est le président de la République
oui je travaille là docteur
j'ai plus de batterie
au secours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en même temps c'est hyper compliqué de
parler d'un spectacles c'est très intime
dans une toute ma vie dans ce spectacle
[Musique]
mais avec cette petite touche à la
française qui fait que oui c'est un
stand-up mais c'est certainement le
stand-up du futur j'adore être un bon
papa mais des fois je m'en reviens
compte j'ai décidé l'autre jour j'ai
fait une insomnie j'ai eu envie d'aller
réveiller mes enfants c'est peut-être de
temps en temps c'est pas mal de rentrer
dans la chambre alors c'est chiant ou
pas
il y a vraiment une partie de mon
cerveau qui a dit pédagogiquement ça se
tient bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on respire
1 2 3 4
[Musique]
ok ok ok c'est pas une chorale c'est une
transhumance
en un il faut des poumons c'est l'usine
qui donne de l'air et ça remonte par la
trachée ça traverse le vibrateur là le
larynx qui émet un son pas très beau
d'ailleurs ça fait un peu ça quoi comme
son et au-dessus magie magie 3e chose
troisième étage de la fusée le masque
raisonnateur l'amplificateur toute la
tête et tout ça ça fait une voix alors
oui on n'est pas tous égaux devant la
voie l'humanité nous a offert Maria
Callas mais aussi Carla Bruni
[Musique]
pour la première fois
enfin
[Musique]
la liberté l'exquise liberté le silence
absolu
l'année
1981 sera encore une année difficile
et sur la chose on vous a dit souvent le
mot vous a fait souvent la chose ainsi
de la chose et du mot vous pouvez dire
quelque chose et je gâcherai que le mot
vous plaît beaucoup moins que la chose
c'est à VOUS l'année
2008 s'achève elle a été rude
actuellement mon immeuble est en dessous
tous les locataires du dessous
voudraient habiter au-dessus tout ça
parce que locataire qui est tout de
suite elle est racontée par en dessous
que l'air que l'on respirait à l'étage
au-dessus était meilleur que celui que
l'on respirait à l'étage en dessous
[Musique]
pour un mec un peu le camping c'est pas
mal glacière voilà la famille les
spectacles de famille
j'ai une petite anecdote à raconter sur
deux souliers qui me revient
j'ai le temps de le faire je demande la
régie parce que j'ai le temps ok non
parce que je suis très à cheval sur la
ponctualité c'est à dire un point commun
que j'avais avec l'ancien ministre
Robert Boulin vous souvenez de Robert
Boulin celui qui a mal fini à
Rambouillet oui ben justement il était
lui il est alors il était à cheval sur
la ponctualité mais alors
incroyable il demandait tout le temps je
suis dans les temps je suis dans les
temps
c'est pas moi
André Dussollier non juste une fois on
l'avait invité à ce moment mardi et
alors il avait dit il nous avait dit si
si vous pouviez faire un débat sur le
foot je c'est ma passion quoi le
football donc on verra sur le foot
et il dit pas un mot mais pas un mot et
puis après on se retrouve en loge et il
dit oui mais le mec il dit ça c'est pas
vrai machin
et je dis mais pourquoi tu l'as pas dit
avant il dit parce que je l'esprit
d'escalier
j'avais pas un mot qui me venait pendant
le débat et après on est resté jusqu'à
3h du matin par les Français
alors on parle de famille et de
spectacle familiaux alors avec avec
notamment avec notamment le monde de
mentors le monde de Peter Pan l'année
dernière on avait fait le livre de la
jungle avec la même compagnie super
décor super musique comédie musicale
comédie musicale pour les familles on a
mis ça après
ultra raisonnable pour que tout le monde
puisse venir les grands-parents les
parents les petits voilà donc ça c'est
ça ça va être un super spectacle voilà
c'est l'homme qui ne voulait pas grandir
absolument et après d'autres adaptations
mais là c'est une comédie musicale
absolument enfin voilà et vous dites
avec la glacière parce que toute la
famille peut venir quoi avec des
sandwichs du coca et après on aura aussi
les walkids rien à voir spectacle
musical qui joue avec des truments
d'enfants voilà et ils reprennent tous
les morceaux des années 90 donc je pense
que c'est plus les parents qui vont
traîner les petits au spectacle que
l'inverse je les ai déjà fait je les
connais c'est génial voilà on peut
regarder d'autres exemples allez
[Musique]
tous les enfants grandissent
tous
sauf un
[Musique]
et s'il vous emmenait vers un monde
lointain
[Musique]
le soleil se noie dans l'horizon
un monde où vous n'aurez plus jamais
agrandir et où chaque jour est une
aventure mais peut-être l'avez-vous tout
simplement oublié deuxième étoile à
droite et tout droit jusqu'au matin
[Musique]
de panique au pays imaginaire
quand tu vois la tasse c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok Élancourt on vient jouer chez toi le
4 mai prochain au prisme alors ramène
toi ok baby
[Applaudissements]
guitare la musique
donc je préfère pas parce que les gens
ils vont pas aimer
là il va y avoir des bons je sais pas
par qui on commence Chimène Badi Chimène
Badi Chimène Badi qui reprend Piaf pas
mal non
je suis en PLS
donc un gars de la police et qui reprend
du bras c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable on va le voir tout à l'heure
donc
notamment le pianiste de Barbara café
vingt ans avec Barbara donc voilà donc
voilà donc ça on est pas mal et puis il
y a un duo c'est incroyable c'est Michel
Jonasz et son pianiste et son pays voilà
qui va reprendre tout ça mais version
Piano Voix avec quelques son répertoire
tous ces grands succès
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
du saut en blanc
elle fait du bon croyez-moi
on n'a pas mal ici c'est mieux chez moi
ton don qu'un slow commence
et bien voilà
c'est ça
et ça sera mieux
c'est ce morceau là j'espère que ça sera
mieux j'espère voilà Jean-Yves et Michel
donna c'est c'est probablement l'un des
plus gros créateurs français absolument
c'est incroyable parce qu'il s'est
retrouvé son maison disque à un moment
quoi c'est il y a une période où c'était
compliqué et puis il joue aussi au
théâtre ici absolument
de l'Île-de-France qu'on a qu'on a reçu
l'année dernière ça c'est la première
fois prise 1er spectacle de musique
classique au prisme avec un programme
Mozart
iden haiden qui était le prof de Mozart
voilà et ça il faut venir voir 45
musiciens sur scène ouais et puis c'est
tous des génies de la musique quoi c'est
très très c'est parfait c'est la
perfection si vous voulez avoir une idée
de la perfection faut venir voir ce
genre de truc oui parce qu'en plus l'on
dit c'est les meilleurs musiciens
d'Île-de-France donc c'est et en plus
ils sont très jeunes très bons très
talentueux et ça fait très très bien
marché l'année dernière donc voilà
c'était c'est la deuxième fois qu'on va
les recevoir au prisme et j'espère qu'on
aura l'occasion de les programmer aussi
ce genre d'installer ce rendez-vous
classique ils sont tous sur scène là
comme ça ils sont tous sur scène ils
prennent tout le plateau et il veut dire
que l'acoustique de ce prisme est
absolument génial c'est un très beau
rapport sens très bien très bien très
bien sonorisé on est bien assis les
photos sont sympas aussi il y a du
gospel mais oui Harlem Gospel quoi qui a
fait qui fait des tournées mondial qui a
joué avec Youtube avec Pharrell Williams
ils ont joué devant Obama ils ont joué
devant Jean-Paul de devant vous en fait
c'est un truc de papes enfin voilà c'est
c'est spectacle là aussi succès succès
mondial incroyable et incroyable regarde
non
même si un jour je deviens comme je le
redoute chanteur pour femme finissante
[Musique]
j'ai voulu voir ta sœur j'ai vu mon
Valais rien tu voulais voir en France
elle était dans le pantin je voulais
voir mes anciens laser j'ai vu les
fleurs du
[Musique]
je me trompe mon cœur dans du papier
d'argent
[Musique]
numéro d'appel
aux abonnés absents
les chansons d'amour
resteront là dans nos pianos
[Musique]
j'aurais jeter la clé du piano dans
l'eau
j'irai voir les rois de la brocante
vendu mon cœur trois fois cinq ans tu
sens récipient l'écouter
que ma vie c'est arrêter
quand tu m'inquiétais
on voulait te dire que je t'attends
[Musique]
étant ici je perds mon temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
classique vous avez dit classique
derrière ce titre se cache de géants de
la musique classique avec une sélection
d'œuvres majeures tout d'abord Mozart
avec l'irrésistible ouverture des Noces
de Figaro et ses fusées de notes si
festives
[Musique]
vous aimez Mozart et bien on vous
emmerdez avec la plus ambitieuse de
toutes ces symphonies la symphonie
Jupiter qui comme son nom l'indique est
une œuvre majestueuse divine même qui
s'achève par une immense fugue
orchestrale avec quatre thèmes musicaux
entendus précédemment dans l'oeuvre et
qui cousue ensemble semble se courir
après avec une précision d'écriture et
une beauté abstraite digne d'un
Jean-Sébastien Bach
[Musique]
dans ce programme nous entendrons
également le père de la symphonie celui
qui fut le professeur de Mozart et qui a
donné ses lettres de noblesse au genre
musical roi des orchestres c'est Joseph
Hayden dont on entendra une musique de
scène très peu connue son île déserte
qui sera une découverte pour beaucoup en
tout cas pour moi
de Hayden toujours nous entendrons l'une
des plus belles symphonies la symphonie
londonienne qui l'écrit lorsqu'il est à
Istanbul non à Londres et qui n'a rien à
envier à la grandeur de la symphonie
Jupiter
[Musique]
mon dieu
même si j'ai tort
laissez-le moi
un peu
même si j'étais
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas mal tout ça plutôt pas mal
voilà j'espère que cette programmation
aura le loisir de vous plaire
on va dépoussiérer un peu le décor on va
installer les musiciens ils vont jouer
40-45 minutes et puis après on se
retrouve au bar donc le bar et les
musiciens pas n'importe quelle musicien
David pourradier David pour addier
un organiste avec l'argument formidable
et alors ils vont faire
un hommage à Nougaro
mon ami Nougaro voilà exactement donc on
va on va laisser les gars
aiment la castagne c'est ça c'était mon
copain de Toulouse Nougaro et c'est
formidable parce qu'ils vont faire alors
j'ai assisté aux répétitions restez là
vous allez vous régaler c'est absolument
formidable absolument et voilà et donc
une fois qu'on aura eu écouter ce
concert reboire après après on va aller
voir
un coup un petit cocktail Laurent mazory
vous a réservé vous allez on va passer
dans les rangs donner une coupe de
champagne à tout le monde
alors on va plutôt vous donner du site
parce que je sais plus quel cas on a on
a réservé mais les budgets vous avez
après vous d'ailleurs on a une
démonstration sur la crise de la dette
qu'on avait prévu de faire avant on l'a
fait pas on la passe pas
le premier adjoint finance aussi bon on
fera une soirée spéci sur la crise de la
dette cidre chipster
vu de l'an dernier si vous avez enlevé
des étiquettes
recongelées qui restent éventuellement
des vœux avant le covid non mais elles
sont très bonnes hein une fois décongelé
ça se voit pas du tout 97 oui
97 c'est très banane magnifique par
contre on a laissé le ciment avec ça
évite de voir la couleur c'est assez
c'est efficace en fait ils sont prêts où
on meubles encore
5 minutes
non en même temps il s'est quand même du
nouveau matériel
on n'a pas pu les roulettes de pousser
mieux c'est de regarder les autres
travailler quand nous même on fait rien
ça c'est un truc et moi je crois que
c'était le principe de base en fait
c'est efficace
on vous laisse bosser les gars
à tout à l'heure au revoir allez
ou je me fais du cinéma
une fois de fois des fois 20 fois
peut-être
je me fais du cinéma
[Musique]
merci Patrice bonne soirée merci à tout
à l'heure au bar ah d'accord
[Musique]